researchers have uncovered a new
pint-sized dinosaur that may give
paleontologists a better idea of how
dinosaurs evolved from their earliest
days the long necked yodhraj meais the
dawn runner was about four feet long and
weighed only 10 to 15 pounds it was a
carnivore and a fast runner two
individual skeletons were found
side-by-side in the foothills of the
Andes Mountains in Argentina in an area
known as the valley of the moon National
Geographic explorer-in-residence Paul
Sereno says this discovery gives
scientists the earliest look at the
development of the dinosaurs
it was a bipedal - like a predator it
chased down its prey grabbed onto it
with nice grasping hands and munched on
it with with recurved teeth for slicing
flesh it is the best view we have of
where the predatory lineage comes from
where ultimately that the the
descendants like Tyrannosaurus Rex where
they began radioisotopes place the age
of the new species skeletons at about
230 million years old
Sereno and the reports lead author
Ricardo Martinez of Argentina's national
university of san juan described their
team's findings in the January 14th
issue of the journal Science
Martinez calls the find the single best
view we have of the birth of the
dinosaurs the area in which Lladro Mia's
was found was once a Rift Valley in the
southwest corner of the supercontinent
Pangea volcanoes over time spewed ash
into the valley and sediments covering
the skeletons accumulated a thickness of
more than 2,000 feet today we can look
at it as a mounted skeleton we can
actually put flesh on it
this is the most complete picture we
have of what a predatory dinosaur
lineage what it looked like at the very
beginning and it was small but nasty
this animal was fast
eeeh Dromi is is believed to be a
precursor to later meat-eaters called
theropods
and eventually to birds
you